I want to know we're cared about and we
all want to be cared about equally and
on that subject my talk at the table is
the u.s. women's soccer team one of the
most successful female sports teams in
American history but the players have
been arguing that they are not being
treated the same as the men's team but a
federal judge threw out the equal pay
claim in their lawsuit on Friday though
he will allow them to go forward and
fight other issues like travel and
medical support a trial is now set for
June and the team's co-captain Megan
Rapinoe is going to join us now from
Greenwich Connecticut Megan good morning
good morning how are you doing this is
how we're doing all right we appreciate
you continuing to come on and talk about
this case so publicly and being so
transparent about it I think the first
question has to be this has been a four
year fight you were asking for 67
million in back pay at a minimum and the
judge said nope through the whole thing
out what's your reaction
I mean shocked to be honest very shocked
and and of course disappointed in this I
didn't I didn't feel like the the ruling
really captured the heart of what we're
after if we were under the men's
contract which for the record we asked
to be an amend contract it was
repeatedly refused to us not only in the
structure but in the total compensation
if we were under that contract we would
you know earn at least three times
higher then we have the argument that
we've earned more over the course of the
time we're talking about then the men's
team really misses the hook merely says
the whole point we've won two World Cups
and we've won basically a game that we
played darn near so to have that
compared in that way and sort of missing
the fact that we've outperformed the
men's team just to say that we earned a
little bit more money I feel like really
misses the heart of the gender gender
discrimination suit that we've brought
against the Federation yeah well Megan
you touch on a really important point
here that is central to the judges
argument in in dismissing the pay
portion of this and neither one of us
are lawyers but I think as a matter of
public argument we can understand this
the judge is saying that the women could
have negotiated a different contract but
chose not to
and the man negotiated the one that they
did
you can't now go back and say hey we
wish we had done it differently that's
his position what's your response to
that as I'm sure many women who have
been in our position I can sympathize
with we did ask for the same for the
same contract and we asked for the same
amount of money and that was repeatedly
and then no one certain terms told to us
that that was not going to be possible
so for the for the ruling to sort of
imply that you know we were peachy King
with the original deal that we got and
now that we're understanding that we
could have had more money and so we're
going back on it is very frustrating for
us at the time we felt like we
negotiated the best deal that we were
offered but at the time it was very
clear as well that the money that we
were going to be paid or the money that
we could even negotiate with was going
to be far less than what was being
offered to the men yeah so the Women's
National Team has said they're going to
appeal you're gonna be part of that
appeal but the US Soccer Federation has
said they're looking forward to charting
a fair path forward those are their
words does that potentially mean there
could be a settlement here are you open
to that I think that we've been very
transparent about our openness to a
settlement ultimately what we want to
get to is something that's fair and
equal and if that comes in the form of a
settlement
we are definitely open to that I don't
think anybody is dying to go into
litigation or go to trial or go through
a lawsuit it's been a very arduous
process for us as players so we're
always open to that but with that we're
not going to settle we know what we're
worth we feel very strong in our case
even with this ruling maybe even even
stronger now so a settlement is always
on the table we'll will always have open
ears to that but it'll be nothing less
than well yeah I should clarify
something which is important here I said
that they wanted to chart a fair path
forward the exact word and the quote is
actually a positive path forward on that
front in these four years you've been
having this fight there have been
changes atop the leadership structure of
US soccer there's now a new president
Cindy cone she's a former member
of the Women's National Team I'm curious
is she reached out to you as a fellow
player to say hey let's work out a deal
I have not heard from her since the
ruling we haven't had a conversation
with her as players prior but I know the
kind of acts falls on on the head of the
president and I think that cindy has a
very big job ahead of her but I don't
think we can let the board off as well I
think that the Board of Directors has
you know huge decision decision-making
role within u.s. soccer and they always
have so I think they need to be a part
of this conversation as well and it
needs to come from bull Cindy who is
obviously the figurehead but from the
board as well and again always open that
conversation we are always willing to
listen but in the absence of something
that truly is fair and equal I'm not
sure a positive path is really what
we're after
yeah former Vice President Joe Biden
leading contender for the Democratic
presidential nomination has voiced his
support for your position saying if he's
vice if he's president or when he's
president he will push the equal pay
initiative is he part of your plan going
forward and and speaking of your
alliance with him I am curious you
appeared with him in a video interview
just a day before he appeared on Morning
Joe to address for the first time the
Torah Reed allegations since you've been
so closely lined with him and since he's
behind you in this fight for equality
what did you think of his reaction to
those allegations and how do they affect
the campaign I mean I think all
allegations of sexual assault need to be
taken very seriously
you know I welcome the media talking
about it and welcome a full
investigation I think that any woman who
comes forward deserves that in terms of
his support for the lawsuit we welcome
any and all support for both sides of
the aisle and we have had a lot of
support on both sides of the aisle
across the political spectrum about this
I think that this issue goes beyond
politics and goes beyond partisanship
and I think this is just an issue really
of human rights
of what is fair and equal under the law
all right Megan Rapinoe thank you again
for coming on to talk about this issue
we will have you on for the next chapter
appreciate it